*slap*
It's been a long day and I've been working pretty hard
I'm getting a little tired so I figured I should probably get some coffee
You may have noticed that your screen is a bit different today
You're actually watching a 3D, 180 degree VR video
Youtube approached us and asked us if we would be interested in experimenting with a prototype camera to make an entire vlog with
It was an interesting proposal so we rigged it up to a gimball and tried to see if it was possible
This is not a sponsored video by the way
You know, I said I was going to get some coffee but really... I just wanted to ride the one-wheel some more
*spots a gap* ooooohhhh. Let's go through here
So. I had paint on my hands and took my ring off to wash my hands.
I sat on a table in the back prop room and I forgot to put it back on
and then at some point in the day somebody else knocked it off the table somehow even though we don't use that table that much
and later that evening I realised that I was misisng my ring and I went outside and looked for it. I looked round desks and I couldn't find it
and I was like... welllll. It might just be gone
The thing is I'm getting a nicer one to actually wear everyday
uhm
So, it wasn't like...
the biggest deal in the world. It was gone but it still kinda sucked as it was a sentimental thing
The tricky thing is to ask yourself. It's a risk or reward scenario.
Do I not tell Ivy and hope she doesn't notice and either hope to:
A) Find the ring (or)
B) buy another ring in time... that I stopped wearing this one
and there by escape unscathed without getting in trouble
or
Do I tell her?
Get in trouble
but
much less trouble than I would be in if she would find out. Say... a week down the line
that I lost the ring a week ago and didn't tell her
So it's a really like
it's a really big conundrum
Do I tell her?
Do I don't tell her?
and.
well guys. I'm a risk taker
So I didn't tell her
and sure enough this morning
I come in and Carmichael goes 'Hey NIKO! You misisng something?'
... well ... I guess I am. :'(
and he hands me the ring
and he saves my life
*Amazing Niko Laugh™* & Carrmichael joining in with the laugh
yep. You would've been murdered
I would have been murdered
Today
Sword fighting in the office
*Iron Man Masks Face Lid Closes*
*laughing*
oh sh*t (Yes!!! #adfriendly in the captions too!)
Jake vs Cmike
*tense music + feet squeaking on floor*
You guys commit
(CMIKE strikes!!! Unfortunately, it' super uneffective)
(More fighting and tense music) O_O
He's dead!!! (not really, dw. He's still alive. Somehow)
I'm gonna put this on the Corridor Card
or right? *winky face* Sounds good.
What you getting?
Gonna validate this ticket
I got one
oh you got one? awwww. :'(
We're here to try the brand new... uh... pinapple mango cream
I have no idea what to expect
Tastes like a poppsicle
Just like a... one of those.... orange cream bars
Yea! Exactly! (He gets me)
A mango?
ugh that's good
This is like weird
It's like there's creamy bits and there's also really intense mango bits
It's hard to do it with one hand
alright Nick. What should we do now? Should we just go riding round little Tokyo?
Check out a little tokessss?!?!
Yea!!! Let's go check out some little tokes
hey nick
nick
SLAP
slap
tiny slap
more tiny slapping
DOUBLE SLAP!!!
Smooth routine of coming up with wacky ideas
and executing on them and it's kind of a creative groove after lifeline I feel myself in
uhm
but ergh. Yea. Right now I'd say say this beast
movie idea that we're working on right now
oh it's the main thing taking over my life
What's the biggest
hurdle that you guys are facing right now in development of that?
ugh... right now there's not hurdles so to speak as it is just simply
making it, ya know?
like
we are
trying to make it and
making a project that big is a lot of work
gotta start somewhere
and that somewhere is anywhere
huehuehue
but just doing something and working on it
let us know what you think of this experiment down below and if you want to see more interesting camera experiments in the future...
please consider subscribing.
(I did. You won't regret it)